Your users love your app.
They store all of
their content there.
They share things.
They literally squeal in
anticipation and delight
when there's an
update available.
They're all your number one fan.
But then they get a new phone
and use Tap & Go to transfer
their account and apps across.
They open up your app
but nothing's there.
With an Android M, we've turned
on full updates and backup
for apps, targeting the
end release and above.
My name is Matthew, working
on Play Services Back
Up and Restore, and I'm going to
walk you through these changes.
Not to put words in
your brain, but you
might be thinking that this
kind of is already handled
by data syncing frameworks.
There's Parse, there's
Firebase, there's
the Android Sync Framework,
the Google Play Games API.
It's a long list.
But any data fetching
is going to be
tied to some sort
of user account
requiring a login before you
can start pulling down the data.
Backup and Restore still
requires an account,
but the account is the
user's Google account
is set up elsewhere.
By the time the user enters your
app, the data is already there.
And then they still need to
consume any welcome screens
and re-accept any
Terms of Service.
When an app is restored
from an ancestral device,
all of the persisted
user state that
existed on a previous
device, will now
exist on a new one as
an exact duplicate.
If you're smart about what
configuration you persist
and how you persist
it, you can drastically
shorten you app's
out of box flow.
The most powerful
part of this is
that once you build your
app against the MSDK,
it will just start backing up.
Let's pause for a moment
to let this sink in.
It means that with
no further effort,
as soon as you download
the M developer SDK
and rebuild your app against it,
your app will start backing up.
Backups are run,
at most, once a day
and use the Job Scheduler API
as reintroduced in Lollipop
to only run when
the device is idle
and connected to
Wi-Fi and power.
Your app has no control
over scheduling backups.
The backed up data
is encrypted at rest
in the user's
Google Drive account
and is not counted
against their drive quota.
For now, we've
capped the data size
at about 25 megabytes
per app per user.
Be careful.
If your app hits this limit,
it will stop backing up.
Now a restore will
happen at install time.
Whenever an app is installed and
we have some corresponding data
present in Drive.
Restore is not
restricted to apps
installed by the Play Store.
Side loading an
app, for example,
or using a third party app store
will still initiate a restore.
Whatever connection is
used for the app download
is also going to be used to
download this extra restored
data.
All right.
We've covered that all apps
targeting [INAUDIBLE] will
automatically start backing
up with no further effort
from anybody.
Let's cover how to opt out.
If you don't want
to use the feature,
you can add the
application attributes,
allow backup, false
to you manifest.
OK.
Now that all the lame-ohs have
left to go disable backups,
let's get to be cool stuff.
For example, what
not to back up.
It's not a good idea to back
up certain pieces of data.
For example, user credentials
or device-specific tokens.
Let's look at Google
Cloud Messaging.
When you register your app with
the Cloud Messaging back end,
you get a device-specific
ID that your server
uses to push notifications
to that specific device.
If you try to restore this
ID onto another device,
it just would not
work, or rather, it
would work but your
server would just not
be able to send any
messages to this new device.
So you really have
to be careful.
Think about the data that
you're persisting to disk
and think about how well it
carries over to a completely
different device.
We've made it easy
to exclude data
that you might not want
stored in the Cloud
or that doesn't make sense
to restore across devices.
You add a manifest, flag the
points of an XML resource
files.
The XML file is easy.
It's a series of include and
exclude tags, each of which
specifies either a directory or
a file, along with the domain
that the data belongs to.
An Exclude targets
how you would specify
that you want to ignore a
specific file or directory.
By default, the backup set
is produced reductively.
That means you start
with everything
and then you strip
things out with Excludes.
Take this example.
This is saying that I want
to back up my entire data
directory except for the
device info database.
Now, in some cases, it's
kind of inconvenient to have
to enumerate every single
thing you want to exclude.
So there's also an Include tag.
Specifying an Include
changes the default behavior
from back up everything
except whatever I explicitly
took out, to only back
up the data I ask you to.
Take this example.
The only file that
will be backed up is
my_important_file.txt.
In other words, having
an Include tag changes
the backup logic
from being reductive,
where you start with everything
and remove, to constructive,
where you start with
nothing and then you add.
Next, we'll talk about exactly
what these domains are.
Any time an app
creates a file, it
isn't going to the
app's root directory
but rather it goes into some
Files directory underneath.
Similarly, when you create
a Shared Preferences object,
it is persisted as an XML file
under some Shared Preference
directory.
Same is true for databases
and extra amount of storage.
Finally, you can
also manipulate data
that resides within the
root directory of the app.
When specifying the data that
you want to include or exclude,
you have to tell your
Backup Manager what
domain it is or,
put equivalently,
which directory to look in.
All righty.
So hopefully at this
point you're thinking,
this is so cool and setting it
up up here is pretty simple,
but it's a little opaque.
How do I know my data is
properly being backed up?
What happens if [INAUDIBLE]
is badly formed?
How can I assure myself that
this thing is actually working?
We have some more
resources to help.
I won't get into the
details in this video
but, if you're interested,
look at the video description
for instructions to turn on
Verbose Logging within your app
as well as how to
manually initiate a backup
and restore and appoint
it to some sample code.
OK.
This has been fun
and, with luck,
if at any point
during this video
you're worried about
being backed up,
you're now sitting
more comfortably.
[MUSIC PLAYING]